Leonardo Silva Revisore
Buonasera, grazie.
Stasera ho dimenticato l'orologio quindi sono costretto a fare questa cosa di mettere il cellulare per avere l'ora.
Dunque noi questa sera parliamo di una pagina di storia italiana che tutti conoscono e su cui però c'è una quantità di leggende, di deformazioni, di miti che circolano,
che io sicuramente stasera dirò delle cose che magari stupiranno qualcuno, dirò delle cose che magari andranno contro a quello che molti pensano essere il senso comune.
Sono consapevole che è perfettamente inutile fare adesso questa premessa, però la faccio lo stesso.
Le cose che dirò saranno fatti, cercheranno di non essere interpretazioni, saranno fatti.
Se vi stupiranno tenete conto che appunto sono fatti accertati tutti quelli che vi racconterò questa sera.
L'altro pezzo forse inutile della premessa è che noi stasera racconteremo un'azione partigiana, la rete di ragazzi che l'ha organizzata,
non racconteremo se non rapidamente alla fine la rappresaglia tedesca e l'eccidio delle fosse ardeatine.
Tuttavia i due eventi sono legati inestrecabilmente nella storia.
Noi stasera raccontiamo un pezzetto di una storia complessa che va ben al di là.
La storia comincia a Roma alla fine degli anni 30, primi anni 40.
A Roma viveva allora un ragazzo che si chiamava Mario Fiorentini.
Era studente di matematica alla Sapienza.
Del resto da grande diventerà un matematico famoso, professore universitario di geometria analitica, mi pare, o qualcosa del genere.
Però Mario Fiorentini che studiava matematica aveva tanti interessi culturali, come molti giovani di allora.
La Roma degli ultimi anni del fascismo è uno strano posto dove c'è specialmente fra i giovani una vita culturale molto intensa.
Ci sono cineforum, c'è teatro d'avanguardia.
E Mario Fiorentini che di mestiere faceva lo studente di matematica, però si interessava di tantissime cose.
Il regista Carlo Lizzani si ricorderà poi di averlo conosciuto da ragazzo, lo incontrava al cineforum per l'appunto.
E dice Carlo Lizzani, sì Mario era un ragazzo con i capelli lunghi, con l'aria romantica, pallido, un poeta.
Mario si occupava anche di teatro. Aveva fondato una piccola compagnia di dilettanti che organizzava spettacoli teatrali nelle borgate.
Sto parlando del 1940, 1941, 1942.
Fra i ragazzi che facevano teatro insieme a lui ce n'era uno più giovane.
Mario dice, era bellissimo. Si chiamava Vittorio Gassman.
Però Mario Fiorentini aveva un piccolo problema rispetto a tanti dei suoi amici studenti romani in quegli anni.
Suo padre era ebreo.
La famiglia non era praticante.
Fino al 38 non ci aveva mai pensato Mario a questo fatto insignificante che suo papà era ebreo.
Viceversa, nel 1938, con le leggi razziali, la cosa di colpo si scopre che è abbastanza importante.
Quando escono le leggi razziali Mario Fiorentini ha uno scatto di orgoglio e decide che questa cosa a cui non ha mai pensato in vita sua, cioè di essere figlio di un ebreo, invece la vuole accettare in pieno.
Decide di farsi ebreo.
Va dal rabbino capo di Roma e gli spiega tutto.
Il rabbino capo di Roma ascolta questo ragazzo entusiasta e poi gli dice, ma senta, lei lo sa che c'è un piccolo problema?
Lei non è stato ancora circonciso, vero?
A questo punto Mario Fiorentini racconterà poi che ha detto, beh magari ci penso ancora un attimo.
La cosa poi passa in cavalleria.
Nel frattempo è scoppiata la guerra e cade il fascismo e c'è l'8 settembre.
E Roma è occupata dai tedeschi.
E pochi giorni dopo l'8 settembre i tedeschi cominciano a rastrellare e rastrellare ebrei.
Vanno anche a casa di Mario Fiorentini, arrestano suo padre e sua madre.
È uno strano momento in cui la dominazione tedesca non è ancora ben organizzata.
Ci sono un sacco di racconti a Roma in quei mesi di gente che viene arrestata e riesce a scappare.
In modo rocambolesco, passando dalla finestra del bagno, della caserma.
Ecco, anche i genitori di Mario Fiorentini riescono a scappare, si nascondono.
Come tanti altri passeranno nascosti quei lunghi mesi fino alla liberazione di Roma.
È chiaro che in casa non si può più stare comunque.
Mario decide di unirsi ai partigiani.
Entra nella resistenza.
Lui ha 25 anni.
Entra nella resistenza insieme alla fidanzata Lucia.
Lei ne ha 19 di anni.
E per molto tempo vivono nascosti, clandestini.
Vivono soprattutto, dormono, nella cantina di un palazzone sul Celio,
vicino al Colosseo, in via Marco Aurelio.
Palazzone moderno, dove il portiere è un compagno.
Il portiere è un omino di mezza età, piccolo, di statura, magrissimo,
con una figlia novizia in convento.
Però lui è comunista.
Si chiama Duilio Grigioni.
E lascia entrare i partigiani a dormire nella cantina, nella carbonaia del palazzo.
Dormono lì a lungo.
La cantina è umida, è una carbonaia, è inverno.
Alla fine Lucia si ammala.
Lucia si ammala abbastanza gravemente e allora lei e il fidanzato, Mario,
decidono di correre il rischio.
Per qualche giorno tornano ad abitare nell'appartamento deserto dei genitori di Mario.
Nell'appartamento hanno messo i sigilli, ma loro sanno come entrare.
Entra o non lo sa nessuno, per qualche giorno stanno lì.
In questo alloggio, in via Capolecasa, nel pieno centro di Roma.
Sono i primi di marzo del 44.
Roma è occupata dai tedeschi da sei mesi.
E un pomeriggio, verso le due, Mario si affaccia alla finestra.
E sente il rumore di una colonna tedesca che arriva marciando da Piazza di Spagna.
E si sta avvicinando.
Quando passano sotto la sua finestra, Mario racconterà poi,
ho riconosciuto, dice, le stesse divise verde marcio
degli uomini che erano venuti a prendere suo padre e sua madre.
E' un'intera compagnia, sono più di 150 uomini in assetto di guerra,
con i mitra a tracolla, i nastri delle munizioni incrociati sul petto,
bombe a mano alla cintura.
La colonna si snoda per più di 100 metri,
attraversa via Capolecasa e si allontana verso Via del Tritone.
Mario si sporge dalla finestra e vede che la colonna attraversa Via del Tritone,
arriva all'imbocco del traforo, parlo per i romani, penso che ce ne sia più di uno,
e arrivata all'imbocco del traforo, gira a sinistra e imbocca una parallela di Via del Tritone.
La parallela si chiama Via Rasella.
A Mario viene in mente che contro quella colonna si potrebbe tentare un'azione.
Nei giorni seguenti ne parla con i compagni.
Mario Fiorentini comanda un GAP, che a dirlo così sembra chissà cosa,
vuol dire 4 o 5 ragazzi organizzati da una gerarchia del Partito Comunista.
Ne parla con i suoi, ne parla con i compagni di un altro GAP, altri 4 o 5 ragazzi.
Il capo è anche lì un altro studente, stavolta di medicina,
si chiama Rosario Bentivegna,
sa sa per gli amici, perché è di origine siciliana, anche se è nato a Roma.
Rosario ha 21 anni, appunto studia medicina,
ha una famiglia di patrioti, ha un bisnonno che era colonnello di Garibaldi.
Mario Fiorentini racconta di questa colonna che attraversa,
cantando canzoni tedesche, il centro di Roma.
E dice, io sono stato a vedere per due o tre giorni,
passa tutti i giorni alla stessa ora.
Gli altri dicono, va bene, veniamo a vedere.
Il 18 marzo si incontrano nella zona e aspettano,
la colonna non passa.
Il giorno dopo si incontrano di nuovo, il 19 marzo,
stanno lì ad aspettare,
la colonna non passa.
Mario Fiorentini ci rimane malissimo,
dice, ma io ho visto per parecchi giorni, passavano,
vi lo giuro, sempre alla stessa ora.
Va bene, veniamo ancora domani.
Il 20 sono lì a vedere.
20 marzo 44.
La colonna passa.
Dall'angolo della strada Sassà Bentivegna
li vede passare cantando in tedesco nel cuore di Roma
e mormora agli altri,
ma questi bisogna attaccarli.
Ecco, qui è bene che ci fermiamo
a raccontare un po' cos'era Roma in quei mesi.
Perché uno dei grandi equivoci
che si sono creati intorno all'attacco di Via Rasella
consiste nel considerarlo come un episodio isolato,
senza contesto,
come se una bomba fosse scoppiata all'improvviso
nel bel mezzo di una città pacifica.
Roma è una città che è stata conquistata dai tedeschi
dopo l'8 settembre,
con tre giorni di combattimenti
contro l'esercito italiano
e contro gruppi di civili armati
che hanno sostenuto l'esercito.
Tre giorni di combattimenti
che hanno fatto centinaia di morti e feriti
con le donne dei quartieri
che portavano da bere e da mangiare
ai soldati italiani
che stavano combattendo contro i tedeschi.
Roma è una città dove la resistenza è attivissima
e dove ci sono attentati ogni giorno.
Muoiono soldati tedeschi continuamente.
Al processo per la strage delle fosse ardiatine
il comandante della Gestapo di Roma,
Kappler,
testimonierà
nel Tevere
spesso venivano lasciati cadaveri di soldati tedeschi.
Il comandante delle SS a Roma,
il colonnello Dolman,
al processo testimonierà
Roma è stata la capitale
che ci ha dato più filo da torcere.
Capite cosa vuol dire?
I tedeschi occupano le capitali di mezza Europa.
Occupano Parigi,
Bruxelles,
Laia,
Oslo,
Copenhagen,
Belgrado,
Atene.
Roma è la capitale
che ci ha dato più filo da torcere,
dice il colonnello Dolman.
Il maresciallo Kesselring,
comandante dell'esercito tedesco in Italia,
al suo processo ha testimoniato
Roma era diventata per noi una città esplosiva
e per noi era un grave problema.
Kesselring dice
per noi Roma era fondamentale,
erano le retrovie del fronte,
mandavamo lì le truppe a riposarsi
e a un certo punto è diventato impossibile
mandare lì i soldati in licenza
a riposarsi e riprendere un po' di forze
per il fronte.
Perché il fronte è lì,
a pochissima distanza da Roma.
Gli americani sono sbarcati ad Anzio e a Nettuno
e quando sono sbarcati
sembrava che in un attimo
dovessero arrivare a Roma,
poi invece non ci sono arrivati.
I tedeschi li hanno fermati.
I tedeschi, uno può pensare a quello che vuole,
ma la guerra la sapevano fare.
Hanno fermato di netto lo sbarco americano,
gli americani sono inchiodati sulle spiagge di Anzio,
non si muovono più.
Su un muro di Trastevere compare una scritta
americani, resistete,
veniamo noi a liberarvi.
Roma dunque è nelle retrovie del fronte
ed è il centro nevralgico del fronte tedesco.
Tutti i giorni per le consolari
passano i convogli
che vanno al fronte di Anzio.
E perciò Roma è bombardata tutti i giorni.
Gli americani la bombardano tutti i giorni.
Bombardano le ferrovie, le stazioni,
ma le stazioni a Roma sono nel centro di Roma.
Nei dieci giorni,
fra l'otto e il diciotto marzo del 44,
quando Mario Fiorentini e i suoi amici
cominciano a pensare all'attacco di Via Rasella,
i bombardamenti aerei americani,
secondo una stima,
qui devo mettere le mani avanti,
cifre sicure non le ha nessuno,
però circola questa stima,
in quei dieci giorni di marzo
i bombardamenti fanno duemila morti
e ottomila feriti a Roma.
Roma è una città dove la vita è completamente stravolta,
dove c'è il coprifuoco,
il divieto di circolare in bicicletta,
perché nei primi attacchi
i partigiani usavano le biciclette,
perciò il comando tedesco ha proibito,
nessun civile può usare la bicicletta.
È una città dove si fa la fame,
con le file per le patate e per il carbone.
È una città piena di gente nascosta,
militari sbandati,
renitenti alla leva,
ebrei.
È una città piena di sinistrati e di senza tetto.
Il traforo di via del Tritone,
a due passi da via Rasella,
è chiuso perché è pieno di famiglie
che dormono lì.
Le caserme di Viale Giulio Cesare,
invece, sono piene di arrestati,
perché i tedeschi continuamente bloccano
interi quartieri, intere vie,
rastrellano gli uomini
e li concentrano nelle caserme di Viale Giulio Cesare
per poi mandarli a lavorare in Germania.
I tedeschi hanno bisogno di gente,
volontari ce ne sono pochi,
i tedeschi rastrellano e mandano.
Il 3 marzo,
l'attacco di via Rasella sarà il 23 marzo,
20 giorni dopo,
il 3 marzo una donna di 37 anni
che si chiama Teresa Gullace,
madre di 5 figli e incinta,
è davanti alla caserma di Viale Giulio Cesare
con un pezzo di pane per suo marito
che è stato rastrellato.
Quando lo vede dietro le sbarre
a una finestra,
comincia a sgomitare per aprirsi la strada,
finisce addosso a un soldato tedesco,
il soldato tedesco le spara,
la lascia morta lì.
E la storia che poi è stata ricreata
naturalmente da Rossellini
per Anna Magnani
nel film Roma città aperta.
Quel pomeriggio i partigiani attaccano
le caserme di Viale Giulio Cesare
e rimane ucciso un fascista.
Il giorno dopo, il 4,
i partigiani ammazzano
il commissario di polizia di Centocelle.
Il 5 marzo viene ucciso
un ufficiale tedesco sulla via Casilina.
I tedeschi ovviamente rispondono,
arrestano, torturano, fucilano.
Centocelle viene rastrellato
dopo l'omicidio del commissario.
Il rastrellamento fa 25 morti.
Il 7 marzo, dieci partigiani arrestati da tempo
vengono fucilati al forte Bravetta.
Il giorno dopo, 8 marzo,
una colonna di camion tedeschi
diretti al fronte di Anzio
viene attaccata sulla Tuscolana.
Otto soldati tedeschi uccisi.
Il 9 marzo salta in aria
un deposito di carburante della Wehrmacht
in via Claudia.
Il 10 marzo, un corteo fascista
che sfila in via Tomacelli
è attaccato dal gruppo di Rosario Bentivegna.
Quattro morti.
E voi vedete,
ho citato soltanto episodi del marzo 44,
delle settimane che precedono
l'attacco di via Rasella.
È fondamentale sottolineare una cosa
che è controintuitiva,
perciò la sottolineo
invitandovi a darmi fiducia.
È un fatto accertato.
I tedeschi uccidono,
fucilano, arrestano,
ma mai e poi mai
c'è stata una rappresaglia diretta.
Mai è successo
che per un tedesco morto
il comando tedesco dicesse
siccome è morto un tedesco
adesso fuciliamo degli italiani.
Mai un manifesto tedesco
ha detto
abbiamo avuto dei morti
e perciò ammazzeremo degli ostaggi.
Mario Fiorentini
e Sassà Bentivegna
comandano dei GAP.
Cosa sono questi GAP?
Questi gruppi d'azione patriottica.
sono organizzati
dal partito comunista
il che vuol dire
che quasi tutti i ragazzi
che ne fanno parte
si sentono comunisti.
Fra l'altro
varrebbe la pena
di riflettere
sull'importanza dell'educazione
specialmente nelle dittature.
Questi hanno tutti passato
tutta la vita
nella scuola fascista
e sono tutti diventati comunisti.
Il comandante dei GAP
si chiama Antonello Trombadori
sarà poi un dirigente comunista
importante
in quel momento
ha 27 anni
per noi oggi
uno di 27 anni
è un ragazzino.
Antonello Trombadori
è un ufficiale dei bersaglieri
che ha fatto la guerra
e che quindi
è perfettamente in grado
di comandare
questa rete
clandestina
in Roma
salvo che in quel momento
è in prigione
l'hanno arrestato
e sfuggirà per miracolo
all'eccidio
delle fosse erdeatine.
Siccome Antonello Trombadori
è in prigione
comanda i GAP
un ragazzo un po' più giovane
che si chiama Carlo Salinari
nome di battaglia
Spartaco
Carlo Salinari
ha 25 anni
e di lavoro
fa l'assistente universitario
di letteratura italiana
alla Sapienza.
Dopo la guerra
sarà un critico letterario
famoso
marxista
ortodosso
e anche un po' rigido
ma un importante
critico letterario
sarà
come sono strani i destini
il preside di lettere
alla Sapienza di Roma
nel 77
al momento del movimento
studentesco del 77
ma qui siamo molto prima
di anni ne ha solo 25
e comanda i GAP di Roma.
I GAP sono una struttura
gerarchica
Mario Fiorentini
e Rosario Bentivegna
vanno a parlare
con il loro capo
Spartaco
Carlo Salinari
gli vanno a parlare
di questa colonna tedesca
che tutti i giorni
passa
da Piazza di Spagna
a Via del Tritone
a Via Rasella
e gli dicono
che loro vorrebbero attaccarla
Salinari
non è convinto
la colonna tedesca
è troppo forte
150 uomini
loro sono
quattro gatti
Salinari
ha paura
che finisca malissimo
ma la struttura
è gerarchica
anche Salinari
ha qualcuno
sopra di sé
Carlo Salinari
risponde direttamente
al comando militare
del partito comunista
e quindi
a Giorgio Amendola
che anche lui
dopo la guerra
sarà un importante
dirigente comunista
che in tanti di noi
ricordano
che in quel momento
e che è anche
naturalmente
Giorgio Amendola
il figlio
di quel Giovanni Amendola
deputato liberale
che un po'
di anni prima
i fascisti
avevano ammazzato
a bastonate
Amendola
è il rappresentante
del partito comunista
nella giunta militare
del CLN
la giunta militare
del comitato
di liberazione nazionale
è l'organismo
che dirige
la resistenza
in tutta Italia
e in cui sono rappresentati
i sei partiti
antifascisti
la DC
i socialisti
i comunisti
il partito d'azione
liberali
i repubblicani
se non vado errato
Amendola rappresenta
i comunisti
gli altri rappresentanti
sono tutti personaggi
di spicco
ve ne cito solo uno
perché l'abbiamo
conosciuto tutti
nella giunta militare
del CLN
il rappresentante
del partito socialista
si chiama
Sandro Pertidi
dunque
Salinari racconta
al suo superiore
gerarchico
Amendola
la proposta
dei ragazzi
dei GAP
attaccare
questa colonna tedesca
la colonna tedesca
l'ha vista
anche Amendola
e l'ha vista
per un motivo particolare
ve lo racconto
perché è veramente
difficile immaginare
cos'è
la Roma
di quel momento
è un luogo
di contraddizioni
incredibili
Giorgio Amendola
è un dirigente comunista
clandestino
ricercatissimo
ma passa spesso
da Piazza di Spagna
e quindi
ha incrociato
la colonna tedesca
perché lui
spesso
ha bisogno
di andare
al palazzo
di propaganda
fide
che è lì
a due passi
il palazzo
di propaganda
appartiene
al Vaticano
perciò gode
di extraterritorialità
e dentro
il palazzo
di propaganda
vive
protetto
dal Vaticano
un altro
importante
uomo politico
antifascista
si chiama
Alcide De Gasperi
ed è il capo
dell'ADC
Amendola
comunista
ha spesso
bisogno
di discutere
con De Gasperi
democristiano
perciò
se ne va
a piedi
a trovarlo
al palazzo
di propaganda
passa
da Piazza di Spagna
ha visto passare
la colonna tedesca
e Amendola
ai ragazzi
dice
sì
attaccatela
Amendola
ha delle ragioni
precise
per dire questo
la giunta militare
del CLN
è in contatto
col comando alleato
col comando
anglo-americano
e il comando alleato
chiede
attacchi
a Roma
il più possibile
dentro la città
perché i tedeschi
hanno dichiarato
che Roma
è città aperta
è una formula
che conosciamo tutti
per via del film
cosa vuol dire
città aperta
Roma città aperta
vuol dire
noi che siamo
da questa parte
la città però
non la usiamo
non ci stiamo dentro
non la difenderemo
è una cosa
che si fa
fra avversari
civili
quando si vuole
evitare
a una città
il peggio
delle distruzioni
della guerra
peccato che i tedeschi
hanno dichiarato
Roma città aperta
ma in realtà
la usano
Roma è piena
di comandi
e centri di comunicazione
e depositi tedeschi
e come dicevo prima
i convogli
della Wehrmacht
passano tutti i giorni
sulla Tuscolana
e sulla Casilina
diretti
al fronte di Anzio
perciò il comando anglo-americano
chiede
ai partigiani
alla giunta militare
del CLN
attacchi
contro i tedeschi
in Roma
in Italia c'è una vecchia polemica
che io mi ricordo
fin da quando ero ragazzino
ma in fondo
la resistenza
non ha cambiato
niente
dal punto di vista militare
per carità
la guerra
gli americani
la vincevano lo stesso
anche senza la resistenza
però il generale
Mark Clark
comandante
della quinta armata
americana
che il 4 giugno
entrerà a Roma
ha dichiarato
per i miei uomini
era importantissimo
sapere che
alle spalle
dei tedeschi
i partigiani
erano attivi
e che i tedeschi
non potevano stare
mai tranquilli
né di giorno
né di notte
la giunta militare
del CLN
è tutta d'accordo
gli alleati
lo chiedono
e va bene così
bisogna fare
degli attacchi
dentro Roma
c'è solo
un po' di gelosia
per il fatto
che gli unici
che hanno una struttura
militare efficiente
sono i comunisti
in particolare
questa cosa
rode un po'
a Pertini
ve lo ricordate
come era fatto
Pertini
e Pertini
a Amendola
dice
va bene
però
se fate
un'altra azione
grossa
per piacere
ce lo dite
e la facciamo
insieme
perché vogliamo
partecipare
anche noi
ma Amendola
è un comunista
e i comunisti
in quell'epoca
sono sospettosi
Amendola
non si fida
decide che
l'azione
contro la colonna
tedesca
la faranno
da soli
Pertini
dirà poi
che lui
avrebbe preferito
essere informato
si era anche
un po' scocciato
quando ha saputo
che l'hanno fatta
senza dirglielo
però dirà
Pertini
l'azione
l'ho però
totalmente
approvata
quando ne venne
a conoscenza
e dunque
i GAP
cominciano
a studiare
l'attacco
contro la colonna
tedesca
uno oggi
dice i GAP
e sembra
di dire
chissà cosa
in realtà
fanno capo
a un partito
clandestino
fuori legge
da vent'anni
che esiste
a malapena
Roma è una città
di due milioni
di abitanti
allora
gli iscritti
al partito
comunista
sono a malapena
3.000
i ragazzi
dei GAP
sono partigiani
improvvisati
senza nessuna
esperienza
a corto
di armi
di munizioni
quelle poche
armi e munizioni
che hanno
le hanno
perché a Roma
esiste anche
una resistenza
militare
monarchica
organizzata
da ufficiali
del regio esercito
che rispondono
al governo
di Badoglio
e del re
al sud
e che hanno
accesso
ai depositi
del regio esercito
solo gli ufficiali
dell'esercito
riescono a procurare
armi
esplosivi
e ovviamente
fornirle ai partigiani
comunisti
qualche discussione
c'è
però poi alla fine
le danno
perché gli ufficiali
hanno le armi
e gli esplosivi
ma i comunisti
li usano
a capo
lo sapete
della giunta
militare
badogliana
diciamo così
monarchica
fino a pochi mesi
prima
c'era il colonnello
Montezemolo
pluridecorato
di guerra
che poi morirà
alle fosse ardiatine
quel momento
l'hanno arrestato
in prigione
ma la giunta militare
continua a funzionare
e fornisce armi
anche ai comunisti
certo
sono quelle che sono
sono armi italiane
di seconda mano
funzionano
fino a un certo punto
gli esplosivi
spesso non esplodono
le armi
si inceppano
un po' di tempo
prima
sei ragazzi
dei GAP
tutti armati
di mitra
hanno attaccato
dei camion tedeschi
a torde schiavi
e tutti e sei
i mitra
si sono inceppati
sono mal armati
quindi
e oltre a questo
oltre a questo
non fanno una bella vita
vivono in clandestinità
che non è una cosa
eccitante
vivere in clandestinità
vuol dire
annoiarsi
passare giornate
intere
chiusi
in una cantina
vuol dire
fare la fame
perché non è che puoi
tornare dalla mamma
a mangiare
ogni tanto si
in gran segreto
ma ci sono giornate
in cui non sai dove mangerai
mangi in trattoria
quando l'oste
è un compagno
e allora ti fa mangiare gratis
oppure mangi in trattoria
quando l'oste
non è un compagno
ma il cameriere sì
e allora il cameriere
di nascosto dal padrone
ti riempi il piatto
due volte di patate
in modo che poi
esci sazio
vuol dire
una fatica bestiale
perché i tedeschi
l'abbiamo detto
hanno proibito anche solo
di circolare in bicicletta
i tram funzionano
quando possono
e quindi chi è in clandestinità
si fa ogni giorno
chilometri e chilometri
a piedi
e poi
e poi si dorme in cantina
appunto
si porta per mesi
la stessa camicia
lo stesso vestito
gli stessi calzini
c'è una testimonianza
di una ragazza
che fa parte
di questi gap
fa parte del gap
di Sassà Bentivegna
e della sua fidanzata
e dopo si sposeranno
anche
si chiama Carla Capponi
Carla Capponi
poi in seguito
racconta
eravamo tutti
magrissimi
pallidi
gli abiti
cominciavano
a caderci addosso
le scarpe
avevano la suola
già più volte
rappezzata
e c'era chi portava
ancora in pieno
inverno
zoccoli di legno
anche dormire
in cantina
non è divertente
specialmente
per le donne
Carla Capponi
che appunto
dopo la guerra
sposerà
Rosario Bentivegna
e sarà deputato
comunista
a Roma
Carla Capponi
in quel momento
è una ragazza
di 25 anni
è una signorina
di buona famiglia
un altro ragazzo
dei gap
Franco Calamandrei
figlio di Piero
Calamandrei
se la ricorda
Carla Capponi
signorina
di buona famiglia
che parlava
con la R. Moscia
e si grattava
i pidocchi
presi
nella cantina
di Duilio
Carla
ha 25 anni
è una signorina
di buona famiglia
anzi sarebbe
la contessina
Capponi
ma la famiglia
è decaduta
il papà è morto
senza lasciare
un soldo
Carla non ha finito
gli studi
si è impiegata
fa la dattilografa
e del passato
è rimasto
solo un grande
appartamento
e per via
di questo
grande appartamento
che Carla
ha cominciato
a fare politica
perché dopo
la caduta
di Mussolini
dopo il 25 luglio
voi capite
Roma
è in ebollizione
i partiti politici
di colpo
sono legalizzati
dappertutto
ci sono incontri
riunioni
discussioni
e qualche amico
dice a Carla
ma voi che avete
un alloggio
così grande
non è che possiamo
usarlo
per fare le riunioni
fra questi
conoscenti
che chiedono
di usare
l'alloggio
dei Capponi
per fare le riunioni
politiche
c'è anche
un comunista
si chiama
Gioacchino
Gesmundo
insegna storia
e filosofia
al liceo
Cavour
a Roma
anche lui
morirà
alle fosse
erdeatine
Gioacchino
Gesmundo
a un certo punto
gli presentano
Carla
e chiede
se può ospitare
nell'appartamento
una riunione
di loro comunisti
e le dice
sarà una riunione
turbolente
dobbiamo discutere
molto
com'è che possiamo
fare in modo
che i vicini
non sentano
le discussioni
e Carla
che è una signorina
di buona famiglia
dice
ma io so suonare
il pianoforte
se volete
Carla so suonare
anche l'arpa
a dire il vero
ma insomma
quel giorno
suona il pianoforte
dice
non finiva mai
la riunione
dei comunisti
ho suonato
tutti i notturni
di Chopin
poi finalmente
la riunione
finisce
e il professor
Gesmundo
le chiede
se la prossima volta
vuole venire
anche lei
alla riunione
così Carla
diventa comunista
e lei
ci ha lasciato
la testimonianza
di cosa voleva dire
dormire in cantina
sulla terra battuta
in mezzo ai mucchi
di carbone
lei è una signorina
di buona famiglia
dice
pensa mia mamma
mi aveva dato
una trapunta
per andare nella cantina
una di quelle
trapunte matrimoniali
io me la arrotolavo
tutta intorno
poi ho visto
che gli altri
dormivano per terra
allora ho detto
vabbè dai
la stendiamo per terra
ci mettiamo tutti sopra
dice Carla
anche questo
dormire come i cuccioli
uno vicino all'altro
ti dà una certa
consolazione
ma c'era molto disagio
essere una donna
non è facile comunque
siamo in Italia
nel 1944
e anche i comunisti
sono italiani
del 1944
non sono mica diversi
dagli altri
quando un ragazzo
dei GAP
che si chiama
Valentino Gerratana
e sarà anche lui
poi un deputato comunista
ma in quel momento
è un ragazzo
si presenta a Giorgio Amendola
con la sua fidanzata
e gli dice
che lei vorrebbe unirsi
anche lei
ai partigiani
e Giorgio Amendola
dice benissimo
così potrà rammendarti
i calzini la sera
ovviamente queste ragazze
si ribellano
loro vogliono essere
alla pari degli uomini
e non è facile
per dimostrare
che lei è alla pari
di qualunque uomo
Carla Capponi
un giorno
su un tram
sfila la pistola
a un milite fascista
di nascosto
e se la porta via
poi quando arriva
dai compagni
con la pistola
se la vogliono
prendere loro
perché le dicono
ma tu sei una ragazza
a te mica serve
allora Carla dice
che lei
la pistola
la vuole usare
e allora le dicono
vediamo
alla prossima azione
spari tu
e così
Carla Capponi
partecipa a un agguato
e uccide un ufficiale tedesco
in mezzo alla strada
poi ha raccontato
che era così scioccata
che scappando
si è dimenticata
di mettere la pistola
nella borsetta
e scappava per la strada
a Roma
con la pistola in mano
e poi quella sera
si è messa a discutere
con il suo capo
che era anche il suo fidanzato
Sasà Bentivegna
dicendogli
non è possibile
ma non si può mica
sparare così alla gente
questo non si può fare
e Rosario Bentivegna
le dice
allora le donne
dovrebbero starsene a casa
e Carla si è ricordata
che in famiglia
quando lei era nata
il padre aveva detto
meno male che è femmina
almeno non farà mai la guerra
e allora Carla ha deciso
di continuare
però tanti anni dopo
racconta
e devo dire la verità
è stata una cosa molto dura
credo che dipenda molto
dal fatto che uccidere
è una cosa contro natura
anche Lucia
la fidanzata di Mario Fiorentini
ve la ricordate
quella che si è ammalata
nella cantina
e che aveva 19 anni
anche Lucia ha parlato
dell'angoscia
di uccidere i nemici
che pure erano
di carne e ossa
come me
e soffrivano
e gridavano
e ancora oggi
risento quelle urla
dice Lucia
tanti anni dopo
però una donna
vuole essere alla pari
con gli uomini
e dopo la guerra
a un certo punto
Lucia viene decorata
con la medaglia d'argento
al valore
e il ministro della difesa
Paolo Emilio Taviani
che passa a distribuire
le medaglie
quando si vede davanti
una donna
le dice
lei signora
è la moglie
pensava che fosse
la vedova
di un decorato
alla memoria
e Lucia gli risponde
no guardi
la decorata sono io
dunque i ragazzi
dei GAP
cominciano a osservare
i movimenti
della colonna
per due o tre giorni
il 20 marzo
è stata decisa l'azione
il 23 marzo
sarà compiuta
per due o tre giorni
cronometrano
i movimenti
della colonna tedesca
e a questo punto
devo entrare
nel dettaglio
di una delle molte falsità
che sono state diffuse
su questa vicenda
è inutile che ve lo dica
che l'attentato di Vieraselle
è una pagina
su cui la memoria italiana
si è spaccata
perché noi siamo
uno strano paese
e allora
una di queste falsità
è quella
secondo cui
la colonna
sarebbe stata composta
da anziani
innocui
poliziotti
non militari
per di più
dell'Alto Adige
cioè mezzo italiani
questa è l'unica
cosa vera
erano dell'Alto Adige
che era stato
annesso
alla Germania nazista
la compagnia
che viene attaccata
è una compagnia
di un battaglione
del reggimento
di polizia militare
Bozen
cioè Bolzano
sono militari
a tutti gli effetti
subordinati
al comando
delle SS
qualche tempo dopo
il reggimento
prenderà il nome ufficiale
di SS
Polizia Regiment
Bozen
cioè
reggimento
di polizia militare
delle SS
Bolzano
non sono giovanissimi
certo non sono anziani
innocui
il più giovane
aveva 26 anni
il più anziano
ne ha 43
è un battaglione
che è impegnato
nei rastrellamenti
per le strade di Roma
quei rastrellamenti
per cui si bloccano
le uscite di una via
e si mandano in Germania
tutti quelli
che stanno dentro
è un battaglione
che è impegnato
nella lotta
contro i partigiani
nei castelli romani
dopo l'attentato
di via Rasella
il battaglione
sarà spostato
in Piemonte
a combattere i partigiani
un altro battaglione
dello stesso reggimento
Bozen
è stato responsabile
di crimini di guerra
e Cidi
in Cadore
ben inteso
questo è interessante
dirlo adesso
ma i ragazzi
non ne sanno niente
quella è una colonna tedesca
è una colonna tedesca
che passa
per il centro di Roma
cantando canzoni tedesche
questo l'hanno confermato
tutti i superstiti
del reparto
gli ufficiali
ci avevano comandato
cantate
tornano
in caserma
dal poligono
di Tordiquinto
dove si sono esercitati
all'uso delle armi da guerra
tornano col mitra
a tracolla
con le bombe a mano
lo dicevo
infilate nella cintura
questo lo hanno confermato
molti superstiti
hanno detto
abbiamo avuto tanti morti
mica solo per la bomba
hanno cominciato
a scoppiare
le bombe a mano
che avevamo innescate
nelle cinture
hanno il mitra in mano
e il colpo in canna
anche questo lo dicono
i superstiti
gli ufficiali ci avevano detto
rischiamo di essere attaccati
perciò colpo in canna
quando tutti i conti sono fatti
si decide di attaccare
il 23 marzo
per puro caso
è l'anniversario
della fondazione
dei fasci di combattimento
un giorno in cui
i fascisti
avevano in programma
grandi celebrazioni a Roma
salvo che il comando tedesco
che comandava davvero a Roma
proibisce ai fascisti
di fare qualunque celebrazione pubblica
o corteo
perché temono attacchi
viene deciso che la colonna
sarà attaccata in vari modi
si farà esplodere una bomba
e altri gruppi di partigiani
attaccheranno
con bombe a mano
e pistole
viene elaborato
un piano d'attacco
piuttosto complicato
che richiede l'impiego
di ben 17 partigiani
fra cui 4 donne
non c'era mai stata a Roma
un'azione di quella scala
d'altra parte
questi 17 partigiani
attaccheranno
più di 150 tedeschi
in assetto di guerra
i 17
c'è un po' di tutto
fra i 17
abbiamo detto
c'è Carlo Salinari
il capo
che sarà ordinario
di letteratura italiana
c'è Franco Calamandrei
che sarà senatore
c'è Carla Capponi
che sarà deputato
c'è Mario Fiorentini
che sarà ordinario
di geometria
c'è Giulio Cortini
che in futuro
sarà ordinario
di fisica nucleare
ma ci sono anche
un portinaio
un tassista
un muratore
un impiegato
ci sono pochissimi proletari
ce n'è solo uno
in realtà
Guglielmo Blasi
è l'unico vero proletario
del gruppo
è molto ammirato
dagli altri
perché è un vero proletario
gli altri non sanno
che è pregiudicato
per furto
e che qualche tempo dopo
si farà beccare
mentre sta rapinando
una casa
e verrà arrestato
dalla polizia
e a quel punto
confesserà
e tradirà tutti
ma questo è ancora
di là da venire
dei 17
nell'arco della guerra
solo uno morirà
Silvio Serra
morirà combattendo
al fronte
contro i tedeschi
parecchi saranno arrestati
torturati
condannati a morte
ma si salveranno
perché il 4 giugno
gli americani entrano a Roma
viene deciso
che la bomba
si farà esplodere
in via Rasella
via Rasella
è una via stretta
in salita
lì la colonna
rallenta
perché è in salita
e serra i ranghi
si fanno i calcoli
c'è un minuto e mezzo
durante il quale
tutta la colonna
è in via Rasella
prima che la testa
svolti
in via Quattro Fontane
perciò bisogna
che la bomba
esploda
durante quel minuto e mezzo
si deve decidere
dove collocarla
per fortuna
via Rasella
ha pochissimi negozi
c'è un punto
particolarmente disabitato
il palazzo Tittoni
è mezzo vuoto
si decide
che la bomba
si metterà
all'ingresso
del palazzo Tittoni
la colonna passa alle due
va benissimo
alle due
non c'è nessuno in giro
di solito
o poca gente
bisogna far esplodere
la bomba
in un momento preciso
qui entriamo
nei dettagli tecnici
nel giro di pochi giorni
si organizza questa cosa
cosa vuol dire
far esplodere
una bomba
che deve esplodere
in un momento preciso
ovviamente non ci sono
i telecomandi
i timer
bisogna che ci stia lì uno
e che dia fuoco
a una miccia
Rosario Bentivegna
decide che lo farà lui
e a quel punto
ci vuole un altro
che stia all'ingresso
di via Rasella
e che gli dia il segnale
perché lui deve sapere
esattamente
in che momento
la colonna
svolta in via Rasella
ci sarà uno
che si toglierà
il berretto
e gli farà segno
questo sarà Franco Calamandrei
il figlio di Piero
calcolano
dal momento in cui
la colonna
svolta in via Rasella
al momento in cui
arriva al palazzo Tittoni
ci mette 45 secondi
i tedeschi marciano
al passo
come un orologio
45 secondi
quindi la miccia
dovrà durare
50 secondi
esatti
subito dopo
l'esplosione
un altro gruppo
di tre uomini
attaccherà
alle spalle
la colonna
con bombe a mano
loro hanno
quattro bombe a mano
non sono vere
bombe a mano
sono bombe
da mortaio
del regio esercito
che degli artigiani
amici
sono riusciti
a modificare
in modo che si riesce
a farle scoppiare
tirandole
e poi
i tre che tirano
le bombe
si metteranno in salvo
e un altro gruppo
di quattro armati
di pistola
subentra
e copre
la fuga
di tutti gli altri
e poi
ogni gruppo
è coperto
da altri ancora
che rimangono
inattivi
se va tutto bene
e intervengono
se si dovesse
creare qualche difficoltà
perciò complessivamente
ci vogliono
17 uomini
e va bene
poi
problemi
e la bomba
come ce la mettiamo lì
come la portiamo
come la nascondiamo
decidono di usare
un carretto da spazzino
all'epoca
gli spazzini
pedalano
dietro al bidone
dell'immondizia
perciò
Rosario Bentivegna
si travestirà
da spazzino
e al momento
della fuga
però ci vuole qualcuno
che lo aspetti
con un impermeabile
in modo che possa
mettersi l'impermeabile
e nascondere
la giacca da spazzino
questo lo farà
sulla sua fidanzata
Carla Capponi
lo aspetterà
all'angolo
di via 4 Fontane
con un impermeabile
sul braccio
se qualcuno la vede
e lei dice
sto aspettando
il mio fidanzato
gli ho portato
l'impermeabile
il giorno prima
il 22 marzo
un gappista
ruba
un carretto da spazzino
in un deposito
dietro il Colosseo
e lo nasconde
nel cortile
del solito palazzo
di via Marco Aurelio
dove c'è la famosa
cantina
Guglielmo Blasi
il ladro
quello che poi tradirà
ma che è un uomo
utilissimo
ruba la divisa
da spazzino
e l'esplosivo
l'ha fornito
il reggio esercito
l'hanno fornito
gli ufficiali
del centro di coordinamento
della resistenza
monarchica
che sono gli unici
come vi dicevo
che a Roma
hanno accesso
a depositi di armi
e munizioni
li hanno contattati
e gli ufficiali
del reggio esercito
hanno accettato
di fornire l'esplosivo
12 chili di tritolo
a ritirare l'esplosivo
ci va un po' per volta
Carla Capponi
le ha dato un appuntamento
in via urbana
lei va a via urbana
e torna con delle borse
un po' per volta
porta tutto questo tritolo
ci va Carla Capponi
perché agli ufficiali
del reggio esercito
evidentemente
trattare con la contessina
piace
gli dà sicurezza
anziché con qualche
operaio comunista
Carla Capponi
dirà poi
erano signori
distinti
piuttosto eleganti
si capivano
fra loro
quanto al contenitore
per la bomba
lì non c'entra
il reggio esercito
quello l'hanno
fabbricato
dei compagni
alla società
del gas
di via ostiense
dove fabbricano
le bombole
del gas
lì
dei compagni
hanno fabbricato
un contenitore
di ghisa
per metterci dentro
il tritolo
dopodiché
sembra uno scherzo
ma bisogna
confezionarla
questa bomba
e la miccia
che deve durare
esattamente
50 secondi
per fortuna
come vi dicevo prima
nel gruppo
c'è un fisico nucleare
non c'è bisogno
di fare la bomba atomica
ma è un fisico
e Giulio Cortini
e sua moglie
confezionano
la bomba
e la miccia
la mattina
del 23 marzo
è tutto pronto
quella mattina
Carla Caponi
si sveglia
lo racconterà dopo
prestissimo
con le ossa rotte
non ha dormito
per l'angoscia
di quello che stanno facendo
per fortuna
c'è da lavorare
c'è da preparare
il carretto
dell'immondizia
bisogna mettere
la bomba dentro
e poi coprirla
con uno strato
di immondizia
qui c'è un dettaglio
che a me è sembrato
surreale
ma che vi dico
perché ci aiuta
a capire
cos'era Roma
in quel momento
Roma è una città
così affamata
che non produce
immondizia
non riescono
a trovare
abbastanza immondizia
da coprire la bomba
ci mettono
tutta la mattina
finalmente
riescono a ammassare
uno strato
di immondizia
per nasconderla
a mezzogiorno
Rosario
Bentivegna
Carla Caponi
il fisico
Giulio Cortini
e sua moglie
vanno a mangiare
alla birreria
Dreher
a piazza
Santi Apostoli
è uno di quei posti
dove un cameriere
compagno
gli riempie
il piatto gratis
ci sono solo patate
ma va bene così
del resto
Carla non manda giù
niente
per l'angoscia
tornano via
Marco Aurelio
Rosario
si mette
la divisa
da spazzino
e parte pedalando
anche Carla
parte a piedi
nella borsa
della spesa
ha le quattro
bombe a mano
che è arrivata
sul posto
dovrà consegnare
al gruppo
che è incaricato
di lanciarle
e poi come sempre
qualcosa va storto
la prima cosa
che va storta
è che Rosario
scopre che pedalare
dietro a questo
carretto
dell'immondizia
così pesante
è una cosa
faticosissima
lui è uno studente
di medicina
una roba così
non l'ha mai fatta
su e giù
per le strade
di Roma
fa una fatica
che non si era mai
immaginato
e poi naturalmente
le cose che possono
andare storte
sono tante
e c'è la legge
di Murphy
se qualcosa
può andare storto
andrà storto
lui è un falso
spazzino
al Quirinale
incontra due veri
spazzini
i quali gli dicono
oh
e che ce fai
da ste parti
e che te frega
risponde lui
scuserete il mio
romanesco
piemontese
ma insomma
gli dice
c'ho un carico
de cemento
gli altri
si mettono
a ridere
sono sicuri
che è un collega
che nel tempo libero
fa la borsa nera
e gli fanno
ma pianta
la faccia
e vede
i prosciutti
e sono lì
che fanno
per aprire
il bidone
rosario
li manda
il diavolo
tira dritto
pedala
per fortuna
quelli si mettono
a ridere
arriva in via
rasella
davanti al palazzo
tittoni
e si ferma lì
alle due
sono tutti pronti
17 ragazzi
ciascuno al suo posto
con le bombe
le pistole
rosario sa che
quando gli fanno
il segnale
deve dar fuoco
alla miccia
sono le due
i tedeschi
sono sempre passati
alle due
quel giorno
non passano
sono le due e mezza
non sono passati
rosario è lì
travestito
da spazzino
che non sa bene
cosa fare
cosa si fa
fuma
ma ha solo
tre sigarette
in tutto
anche questo
è un dettaglio
cosa voleva dire
quell'epoca
e come una di quelle
sigarette
deve accendere
la miccia
alla fine
decide di mettere
tutto il tabacco
dentro una pipa
e tenersela lì
in bocca
dopo un po'
passa uno
vede questo
spazzino
che sta lì
appoggiato al muro
e non fa niente
e gli fa
oh guarda che
arriva l'ispettore
rosario si preoccupa
già
cosa fa
uno spazzino
spazza la strada
rosario
prende la scopa
e comincia a spazzare
la strada
essendo uno studente
di medicina
si accorge subito
che non è capace
di spazzare la strada
è peggio di prima
se lo vedono
capiscono subito
c'è qualcosa
che non va
perciò smette
rimane lì
a fischiettare
dopo un po'
vede uno dei compagni
appostati in fondo
alla via
che si muove
dice
il segnale
arrivano
accende la pipa
non arriva nessuno
intanto si è bruciato
un altro po'
di quel poco tabacco
che si era portato
intanto Carla
ha lasciato
le bombe a mano
al compagno
che deve farsene
carico
ed è andata
ad appostarsi
in un posto
che c'è ancora oggi
e che tutti i romani
conoscono
l'ingresso
del messaggero
in via del tritone
dove ci sono
le bacheche
con l'ultimo numero
del giornale
e la gente va lì
a leggersi il giornale
il posto perfetto
per star lì
ad aspettare
Carla si piazza
davanti alle bacheche
legge il giornale
sul giornale
c'è scritto
che oggi a Napoli
c'è l'eruzione
del Vesuvio
Carla non lo sapeva
la cosa la appassiona
si legge tutto
l'articolo
poi guarda l'ora
si fa tardi
e non succede niente
c'è qualcosa
che non va
all'ingresso
del messaggero
ci sono di guardia
due poliziotti
in borghese
i quali poliziotti
vedono questa signorina
carina fra l'altro
che sta lì
e dopo un po'
vanno e attaccano
discorso
e lei dice
che sta aspettando
il fidanzato
ma i due
non mollano
allora Carla
dopo un po'
li molla lì
risale via
Rasella
passando davanti
a Rosario
vestito da
spazzino
che sta sempre lì
a fischiettare
Rosario la vede passare
dice
è il segnale
accende la pipa
non succede niente
rispegne la pipa
il tabacco è quasi finito
a questo punto
alle 4 a meno un quarto
uno dei compagni
passa vicino a Rosario
e gli dice
oh se alle 4
non sono arrivati
prendi il carrettino
e andiamo via
intanto Carla
è arrivata davanti
a Palazzo Barberini
lì ci sono
dei bambini
bambini che giocano
al pallone
Carla si preoccupa
ha paura che rimangano
coinvolti i bambini
nell'esplosione
perciò
cosa può fare
una signorina
di buona famiglia
va dai bambini
e gli dice
qui non si può giocare
andate a casa
a fare i compiti
i bambini
si allontanano
un po'
e si rimettono
a giocare
a via del traforo
lì c'è un altro
gappista appostato
che li vede
anche lui si preoccupa
che i bambini
si facciano male
allora va lì
ma siccome non è
una signorina
di buona famiglia
sa come si fa
prende il pallone
e lo calcia via
lontanissimo
oltre via del tritone
i ragazzini
gli fanno
fio della mignotta
e corrono dietro
al pallone
e si allontanano
intanto Carla
è ferma
all'angolo
di quattro fontane
i due poliziotti
in borghese
del messaggero
la vedono
che si è di nuovo
fermata
vanno fin lì
e riattaccano
discorso
non si è mai capito
se sospettano qualcosa
o se hanno solo voglia
di chiacchierare
con questa bella ragazza
sono due pappagalli
come si diceva allora
e Carla dice
no
aspetto il fidanzato
ma è in ritardo
poi vede passare
una signora
che conosce
Carla è del quartiere
pieno di gente
che la conosce
è una delle cose
che la stanno angosciando
vede passare
una vecchia signora
amica di sua mamma
dice scusate un attimo
devo andare a parlare
un'amica di mia mamma
vada la vecchia signora
e le fa signora
torni a casa
che oggi non è cosa
c'è aria di rastrellamenti
torni a casa
e in quel momento
compare la colonna
che era stata
al poligono
a sparare
e aveva fatto ritardo
sono le 4
meno 10
in fondo a via Rosella
Franco Calamandrei
si toglie il berretto
per dare il segnale
Carla
ferma a via
delle quattro fontane
vede Rosario
che dopo aver acceso
la miccia con la pipa
le viene incontro
Rosario incontra
un altro gruppo
di bambini
e qui devo dire
fa veramente impressione
pensate questa Roma
piena di bambini
ci sono bambini
dappertutto
fra i piedi
continuamente
una cosa oggi
inimmaginabile
Rosario risalendo via Rosella
incontra un altro gruppo
di bambini
e li caccia via
naturalmente
davanti all'ultimo isolato
c'è il portinaio
che è uscito
a prendere il fresco
e Rosario gli fa
oh ma devi stare proprio qui
vada dentro
quell'altro non capisce
sta lì
rimarrà ferito
dalle schegge
Rosario raggiunge Carla
Carla gli infila
l'impermeabile
in quel momento
si accorgono
che i due poliziotti
in borghese
li stanno guardando
e si stanno muovendo
verso di loro
Carla mette la mano
nella borsa
per impugnare la pistola
in quel momento
passa un autobus
che li nasconde
e loro svoltano
la via
e subito dopo
via Rosella esplode
il resto è storia
muoiono sul colpo
26 tedeschi
altri 6
muoiono nella notte
un altro il giorno dopo
per il tritolo
per le bombe a mano
lanciate dai gappisti
per le loro stesse bombe a mano
che avevano la cintura
e che esplodono
muoiono anche
nell'esplosione
due civili
almeno uno
lo dicono i medici
che c'era qualcuno
che non si è mai più capito
chi fosse
l'altro invece
si sa chi era
era un ragazzino
Piero Zuccheretti
che andava a lavorare
in un'officina
come tutti i giorni
e per sbaglio
era sceso
una fermata
dopo dal tram
e stava tornando indietro
ci sono per terra
più di 30 tedeschi
ma la colonna
ne contava 150
ci sono più di 100 tedeschi
feriti dalle schegge
dai vetri
tutti i vetri della via
sono esplosi ovviamente
ci sono in strada
più di 100 tedeschi
terrorizzati
che sparano a casaccio
da tutte le parti
avevano il colpo in canna
sparano contro le finestre
convinti
che gli abbiano buttato
le bombe dall'alto
sparano dappertutto
uccidono altri 6 civili
tra cui un poliziotto
e l'autista
del questore fascista
di Roma
Caruso
l'autista del questore
era lì vicino
sente l'esplosione
tira fuori la pistola
si mette a correre
verso via Rasella
i tedeschi
vedono questo
che corre con la pistola
lo inchiodano
anche Giorgio Amendola
era passato di lì
poco prima
andava al solito
appuntamento
con De Gasperi
al palazzo di propaganda
era passato poco prima
tanto che i suoi
l'hanno visto
e si sono preoccupati
fosse mai che rimane
coinvolto
Amendola sta andando
da De Gasperi
insieme a un altro politico
clandestino
anche lui
si capisce
Sergio Fenoaltea
del partito d'azione
sentono l'esplosione
Fenoaltea
dice ad Amendola
ma cosa è successo?
credi che siano stati
i partigiani?
è possibile
risponde Amendola
salgono da De Gasperi
anche De Gasperi
ha sentito tutto
e gli chiede
cos'è successo
e non so
risponde Amendola
forse è un'azione
dei nostri gap
e De Gasperi
si mette a ridere
gli dice
ah deve essere così
voi comunisti
uno ne pensate
mille ne fate
sul posto
arriva il generale
Meltzer
il comandante
tedesco di Roma
lì
in via Raselle
è ancora pieno
di feriti
che urlano
e di soldati
impazziti
che sparano
a tutte le parti
c'è già lì
il comandante
delle SS
Dolman
Dolman era uno abile
era sempre sul posto
è arrivato per primo
subito dopo
arriva il comandante
militare
il generale Meltzer
racconta
il colonnello
delle SS
Dolman
che il generale Meltzer
arriva lì
ubriaco fradicio
ma tutti sanno
che è un alcolizzato
e che nel pomeriggio
è sempre ubriaco
il generale Meltzer
ubriaco
si mette a gridare
vendetta
per i miei poveri
camerati
e proclama
che farà saltare
in aria
tutte le case
di via Rasella
il colonnello
Dolman
gli dice
generale
non se ne parla
neanche
i 17
gappisti
si sono tutti
disimpegnati
Rosario e Carla
stanno camminando
a braccetto
come due fidanzatini
in quel momento
per la tensione
pazzesca
a Rosario
viene un collasso
non si regge
più sulle gambe
sono a due passi
da casa
della famiglia
di Carla
decidono di rischiare
Carla lo porta su
la mamma di Carla
gli dà
della coramina
come si usava
allora
e lo rimette
in piedi
a casa
della mamma
di Carla
è nascosta
un'amica
ebrea
la quale
ha una casa
a piazza Bologna
dove vivono ancora
i suoi figli
ma lei non osa
andarci
quindi sta nascosta
a casa
della signora
Capponi
però dice
a Rosario
e a Carla
perché non andate
a dormire
a casa mia
a piazza Bologna
stasera
così
dite ai miei figli
che io sto bene
loro accettano
vanno a piazza Bologna
quella sera
mentre Rosario
gioca a scacchi
con uno dei figli
della signora ebrea
Carla
ascolta la radio
per sentire
cosa racconta
la radio
non racconta niente
trasmette solo
canzonette
uno che invece
ha saputo subito
tutto
è Hitler
nel suo quartier
generale di Rastenburg
in Prussia orientale
e Hitler
dà di matto
un ufficiale
del suo stato maggiore
ha scritto
in due occasioni
vidi il Führer
fuori di sé
in un vero
e proprio
attacco
di follia
quando seppe
dell'attentato
partigiano
di via Rasella
a Roma
e quando seppe
che Parigi
non era stata distrutta
come lui aveva ordinato
prima che
entrassero gli alleati
quella sera
si discute
convulsamente
la rappresaglia
fra il quartier
generale di Hitler
il comando
delle SS
a Roma
Dolman
il comando
della Wehrmacht
in Italia
Kesselring
il comando
della Gestapo
Kappler
questi ultimi tre
hanno tutti detto
concordemente
che loro hanno fatto
il possibile
per ridurre
il numero
delle vittime
era Hitler
che ha perso
la testa
e voleva far
ammazzare
50 italiani
per ogni tedesco
noi
dicono
Kappler
Dolman
Kesselring
gli abbiamo detto
che era una pazzia
che non se ne parlava
neanche
alla fine
siamo riusciti
a abbassare la cifra
alle 11 di sera
Hitler si è calmato
10 italiani
fucilati
per ogni tedesco
però
l'esecuzione
dovrà avvenire
entro 24 ore
Kappler
comandante
della Gestapo
a Roma
e il suo braccio destro
che si chiama
Pribke
passano la notte
a fare l'elenco
dei prigionieri
da fucilare
con la collaborazione
del questore
Caruso
che gli trova
i detenuti
che mancano
al mattino
i morti
sono 32
e loro
hanno 320 nomi
poi arriva la notizia
che è morto
un altro
in ospedale
quindi i morti
sono 33
allora bisogna
aggiungerne 10
i tedeschi
sono precisi
poi i tedeschi
non sono così tanto
precisi
perché quel giorno
a mezzogiorno
cominciano a portare via
da Regina Celi
e da Via Tasso
i condannati
le esecuzioni
alle fosse ardiatine
cominciano intorno
all'una e mezza
del pomeriggio
che durano fino a sera
l'attentato è stato
alle 4 del giorno prima
e Pribke e Kappler
che sono lì
che contano
gli ingressi
alle fosse ardiatine
a un certo punto
si rendono conto
che non gli hanno portato
330 uomini
ma 335
per sbaglio
ce ne sono 5 di più
che si fa?
Kappler e Pribke
decidono
già che ci siamo
fuciliamo anche questi
un superstite
del battaglione Bozen
attaccato a Via Rasella
il furiere
Hans Plach
ha dichiarato
al processo Kappler
virgolette
la rappresaglia
alle fosse ardiatine
fu fatta
nel massimo
rispetto
della legge
alla fine
rimasero
soltanto
ebrei
comunisti
e altra gente
così
nessun innocente
a Roma
quel giorno
mentre i tedeschi
fucilano
335 persone
alle fosse ardiatine
a Roma
quel giorno
24 marzo
tutti parlano
dell'attentato
di Via Rasella
anche se la radio
non ne ha parlato
molti sono spaventati
trovano che
è una cosa
troppo grossa
non era il caso
però tutti
parlano di quello
ma nessuno
sa niente
della rappresaglia
che è stata
compiuta
in segreto
solo il giorno dopo
il 25 marzo
a mezzogiorno
esce il messaggero
con un comunicato
del comando tedesco
che parla
della vile imboscata
eseguita
da elementi criminali
comunisti
badogliani
su incitamento
anglo-americano
e annuncia
che il comando tedesco
per rappresaglia
ha deciso
che per ogni tedesco
morto
10 comunisti
badogliani
saranno fucilati
il comunicato
conclude
quest'ordine
è già stato
eseguito
se vivessimo
in un altro paese
non ci sarebbe
da aggiungere
altro
ma noi viviamo
in Italia
dove i fatti
contano meno
dell'ideologia
dove ognuno
si reinventa
la storia
come piace a lui
e perciò
non possiamo
non concludere
ricordando
l'incredibile
leggenda
che è stata
costruita
intorno ai fatti
di via Rasella
per screditare
i ragazzi
che avevano
attaccato i tedeschi
e la leggenda
secondo cui
i nazisti
prima di compiere
la rappresaglia
avrebbero chiesto
che i responsabili
si presentassero
garantendo
che in quel caso
gli ostaggi
non sarebbero
stati fucilati
questa idea
secondo cui
i gappisti
erano dei criminali
e i martiri
delle Ardeatine
erano morti
non per colpa
loro
ma al loro
posto
questa idea
ha una genesi
che è stata studiata
e risale
all'osservatore romano
il giorno dopo
la strage
delle fosse
Ardeatine
il giornale
del Vaticano
scrive un articolo
in cui racconta
i fatti
e chiama
i morti tedeschi
di via Rasella
vittime
e i 335
fucilati
delle fosse
Ardeatine
virgolette
persone
sacrificate
per i colpevoli
sfuggiti
all'arresto
che ci sia
anche qualcun altro
colpevole
magari di averli
fucilati
il giornale
del Vaticano
non lo dice
la leggenda
vera e propria
secondo cui
i tedeschi
avevano chiesto
ai responsabili
di presentarsi
viene diffusa
già qualche giorno
dopo
dal federale
di Roma
Pizzirani
il quale
deve gestire
lo shock
di una città
che è totalmente
sconvolta
adesso che sta
venendo fuori
quello che è successo
perciò il federale
Pizzirani
mette fuori la voce
che se si fossero
presentati
i colpevoli
la rappresaglia
non ci sarebbe stata
ed allora
un'infinità di persone
nel nostro paese
ci crede
in buona fede
il fatto che
il fatto è
scusate
che i tedeschi
non si sognarono
neppure
di pubblicare
un manifesto
in cui chiedevano
i partigiani
di presentarsi
e neanche
di avvisare
che ci sarebbe
stata una rappresaglia
le fucilazioni
delle fosse
ardiatine
avvennero
entro 24 ore
come aveva ordinato
Hitler
e in totale segretezza
perché come disse
Kappler
al suo processo
avevano paura
che se si fosse saputo
che fucilavano
300 persone
Roma sarebbe
insorta
Kappler dichiarò
che loro
non si erano neanche
preoccupati
di cercare
i veri colpevoli
tanto erano sicuri
che la popolazione
li avrebbe coperti
e anche questo
è indicativo
al processo
di Kesselring
gli fu chiesto
se non avevano
pensato
di chiedere
ai partigiani
di via Rasella
di presentarsi
il maresciallo
Kesselring
disse
eh
a pensarci adesso
non sarebbe mica
stata una cattiva idea
allora gli hanno chiesto
ma non l'avete fatto?
ma no che non l'abbiamo fatto
ha risposto Kesselring
però una volta
che la discussione
è impostata così
non se ne esce più
e così c'è stato
chi ha detto
anche se i tedeschi
non l'hanno chiesto
dovevano presentarsi
lo stesso
chi fa un attentato
poi si presenta
c'è chi ha detto
non dovevano
fare l'attacco
perché sapevano
che i tedeschi
poi avrebbero ucciso
dieci persone
per ogni caduto
e anche qui
infinite discussioni
per decidere
se sapendolo
bisognava fare
l'attacco lo stesso
oppure no
finché gli storici
non se ne sono occupati
e hanno scoperto
che appunto
fino a quel momento
mai i tedeschi
avevano fucilato
dieci persone
per rappresaglia
per ogni caduto
a Roma
c'erano stati
innumerevoli attentati
moltissimi tedeschi uccisi
e mai c'era stata
una rappresaglia
in quelle proporzioni
mai nessun manifesto
l'aveva minacciato
l'unica cosa
che i tedeschi
avevano sempre detto
e ripetuto
e che i gappisti
sapevano
perché quello sì
stava scritto
sui manifesti
era
chi attacca
i tedeschi
sarà punito
con la morte
e il risultato
è surreale
perché i nostri alleati
lo stato italiano
legittimo
allora combatteva
al fianco
degli angloamericani
e uno dei 17 ragazzi
di via Rasella
morirà poi
combattendo al fronte
in divisa italiana
nell'esercito italiano
combattendo
contro i tedeschi
i nostri alleati
sono rimasti
stupefatti
e ammirati
dell'attacco
di via Rasella
il generale
Alexander
comandante
di tutte le truppe
alleate nel Mediterraneo
disse che lui
aveva cominciato
a rispettare
gli italiani
quando aveva scoperto
che Roma
era
virgolette
una città
che ha osato
sfidare
in pieno centro
un battaglione
tedesco armato
sarà per questo
nuovo rispetto
per gli italiani
sarà più probabilmente
perché il giorno dopo
via Rasella
i tedeschi
smettono
di far passare
i loro convogli
dalle consolari
e evacuano
a tutti gli effetti
Roma
sarà per questo
che Roma
che fino al 23 marzo
era bombardata
dagli americani
ogni giorno
dal 23 marzo
per due mesi
non viene più bombardata
però in Italia
molta gente
ha preferito pensare
che l'attacco
di via Rasella
è stato un delitto
e i ragazzi
che l'hanno fatto
sono dei criminali
ed è qualcosa
che ci insegna molto
sul paese
che siamo
grazie
grazie a tutti